aquí tenemos la función fx es igual a
menos x 4 y su gráfica y queremos
encontrar la inversa de f y graficar la
déjame empezar encontrando la inversa de
la función f x para eso tomamos igual a
fx es decir que es igual a menos x + 4 -
x 4 con esto ponemos allí en términos de
x pero para encontrar la inversa debemos
poner a x en términos de g entonces voy
a despejar x voy a restar 4 de ambos
lados para obtener que ye menos 4 es
igual a menos x y luego voy a dividir
entre menos 1 para obtener que menos más
4 es igual a x déjame voltear esta
igualdad para que la variable
dependiente me quede a la izquierda y
nos queda que x es igual a menos más 4
con esto logramos poner a x en función
de y entonces déjame escribir eso voy a
poner que f
a la menos uno es decir me voy a fijar
en la función inversa de i d i es igual
a menos a más 4 y a partir de aquí puedo
cambiar el nombre de la variable sin
ningún problema es decir puedo escribir
que efe al menos 1 de x es igual a menos
x más 4 estas dos funciones estas dos
son idénticas simplemente cambiamos el
nombre de la variable muy bien notemos
que casualmente nos quedó que la inversa
de f la inversa de f es exactamente
igual a efe
es decir f es su propia inversa de esta
manera cuando graphic hemos f inversa de
x la gráfica nos va a quedar exactamente
la misma nos va a quedar justo encima de
algo de este estilo va y esto tiene
sentido por varias razones si recuerdas
en el vídeo anterior dije que la gráfica
de la función inversa es la reflejada de
la gráfica de la función con respecto a
la función ye igual a x
aquí la x es esta línea que es
perpendicular es perpendicular a la
gráfica de la función original y
entonces al reflejar caemos exactamente
en la misma gráfica
si quieres vamos a seguir viendo que
esto tenga sentido notemos que cuando
hacemos
efe 2 caemos en 2 y cuando hacemos efe
de 4 caemos el 0 y si nos vamos ahora a
la inversa
efe de 2 cayenne 2 lo cual está bien de
2 vamos a 2 y con la inversa regresamos
y la inversa aplicada en 0 es igual a 4
entonces
efe nos manda 0 a 4 y efe inversa perdón
efe nos manda 4 a 0 y efe inversa nos
manda 0 a 4 entonces hasta ahí todo
tiene sentido déjame hacer otro ejemplo
a lo mejor para ti ya es muy claro pero
lo voy a hacer por si queda alguna duda
vamos a 5 notemos que efe de 5 es menos
efe de 5 es igual a menos 1 o bien
podemos poner que f manda 5 a menos 1
a menos 1 y ahora qué sucede con efe
inversa en menos 1 efe inversa en menos
uno va a 5 entonces
efe efe inversa en menos 1 es igual a 5
va o bien podemos poner que f inversa
manda menos 1 a 5 y entonces esto esto
tiene todo el sentido verdad es más
hasta podemos verlo con el dominio y con
el rango si por aquí pintamos el dominio
y por acá pintamos el rango esto que
acabamos de hacer nos dice que f
aplicado en 5 por aquí está el 5
entonces al aplicar
efe acá hemos de este lado a menos 1
esta de aquí es efe y al aplicar f
inversa que lo voy a poner en rojo vamos
de menos 1 vamos de menos 1 a 5 y eso es
exactamente lo que queremos que suceda
con la inversa
déjame ponerle aquí efe al menos uno muy
bien vamos a hacer otro problema
aquí tenemos la función de x igual a
menos 2 x 1 y su gráfica vamos a
calcular la inversa y graficar la una
vez más tomamos igual a menos 2 x menos
1 y ahora despejamos x sumando uno de
ambos lados ye más uno es igual a menos
2x
y dividiendo entre menos 2 menos medios
menos un medio es igual a equis voy a
poner la x a la izquierda x es igual a
menos medios menos un medio y voy a
poner ahora que esto es la inversa pero
hay que tener cuidado esto es la inversa
de g no de f entonces nos quedaría que g
inversa de i d g es igual a menos de
entre 2 - 1
medio y otra vez voy a cambiarla por
equis entonces he inversa de x es igual
a menos x medios menos un medio muy bien
vamos a hacer la gráfica aquí ya tenemos
la gráfica de
x estoy acá es igual a gdx voy a poner
en rojo voy a poner en rojo la gráfica
de la función o sea la menos uno de x
como quedaría esta función bueno pues
cortar el eje y en menos un medio y
tiene pendiente menos un medio entonces
sí avanzó 1 bajó 1 se bajó un medio se
avanzó 1 bajó un medio se avanzó 1 bajó
un medio y para atrás voy subiendo un
medio entonces la gráfica quedaría voy a
tomar la herramienta de línea recta
quedaría más o menos
y si quieres para verificar déjame
escribirle que esté de igual
ag inversa de x si quieres para
verificar vamos a trazar la gráfica de
iguala x para ver que realmente una es
el reflejo de la otra
entonces la gráfica de igual a x nos
queda no nos queda por acá queda de aquí
para acá
de aquí para acá sale y en efecto pues
parece ser que la roja es la reflejada
de la azul entonces de esta forma
encontramos encontramos la inversa de la
función recuerda simplemente ponemos de
igual a menos 2 x 1 despejamos x y luego
sustituimos la ye por x y con eso
encontramos la inversa